hello joining myself and Justin Harold
here the game's foot stage at e3 2016 is
Chuck from the coalition here to talk
some gears of war for Chuck how you do
today great you excited to show off more
gears I'm super excited to show off more
gears thanks for having me so how is the
show been so far how was the reception
to what we saw at the press conference
oh really good I mean people were very
excited about all the stuff they saw
yesterday they're excited about the
cross play and about xpa as well so yeah
we're just showing a little bit of a
different campaigns look inside of our
booth here at the show it is especially
coming off of Gears of War remastered
and now going into gears of war for did
that help energize you guys going into
this yeah I mean we really used Ultimate
Edition as an opportunity for the team
to sort of figure out how gears works I
mean taking over epic was a big job
obviously I mean Gears of War is an
iconic franchise so for us we really had
to learn how to do it right before we
did difference so that's what ultimate
edition was for us and we were super
excited about the reception for that and
then obviously after the stuff we showed
last year there's big expectations so
yeah it was kind of nice to be able to
start unveiling that stuff and giving
the fans a chance to see what's really
going on and of course the Xbox play
anywhere and the cross play how much
work is going on under the hood to be
able to make that work ah a lot I mean
it's an initiative for all of Microsoft
and we're really proud to be a part of
that so for us xpa is super exciting I
mean as a gamer I'm really excited about
that right it's you know you play your
game and now it goes with you everywhere
so you know your savegame your progress
your achievements all travel with you
phone whatever platform your own so
that's really fun uh you in the press
conference we saw a little bit of kind
of like this incredible dust storm are
they dynamic they planned that if I play
the same level again it's gonna be the
same dust on the same spot or is it
gonna change a little oh we had to
practice a lot because it is a system
it's not a scripted experience am i okay
oh yeah yeah it's not a demo it's a
script experience so you know it changes
every single time you play it so it's
really unpredictable but that's what's
cool about it is that as you play
through the experience that you're going
to have might be completely different
experience and I'm going to have and I
think that creates a lot of discussion
and a lot of fun between the players how
them can get surely there must be some
kind of boundaries on how far yeah
there's things that you can interact
with and that's part of the discovery of
each of the encounters which is a lot of
fun as well you can play through and not
get any of the interactive stuff that
you saw yesterday like the car the pipes
or or any of that stuff happening but
there are other things obviously that
you can do inside there and the wind
affects everything so it affects the
projectiles as well so in the in the
demo yesterday you saw the saw blades
from the buzzkill flying off in
different directions and the same thing
with the drop shot you really have to
then sort of determine how much the wind
is going to affect it and can the wind
be used in multiplayer with just a
single player no it's only single player
and you know unfortunately multiplayer
fans are really finicky about their
experience so it's you know we might
have one or 2 multiplayer levels for
social play that it will use wind as one
of the things that you can experience
out of there but certainly not for
competitive play you know because gears
is a franchise that is very well beloved
that it has really hardcore fans and and
you guys are coming into it as as a new
studio are there things that are kind of
sacred that you felt like this has to be
the same this has to be really authentic
to gears and were there any things you
were like we want to change this we want
to make this better yeah I think with
every game I mean whenever you going to
do a sequel for a product you have to
try and move the needle a little bit and
make your fanbase a little bit
uncomfortable but for us it was really
important to make sure again that we did
it right before we did it before he did
difference so because we were on a new
engine which is the unreal 4 engine we
actually had to rebuild most things from
the ground up so we were able to create
technologies allowed us to do a mirror
pixel for pixel comparison between gears
3 and what we were building in Gears for
so it's a very authentic experience to
gears and then we started to tweak it
and say ok what other things we can make
different like the clothes cover combat
or the wind effects or things like that
so it's a little bit here a little bit
there but you try and stay true to what
the fans really love and trust me gears
fans are incredibly passionate and they
give us tons of feedback so we have a
lot of that stuff taken into account and
then we sort of move on from there what
was it like creating a new story I mean
obviously the big reveal from the
Microsoft press conference is that we
saw Marcus Fenix is back daddy's home
what was it like kind of coming up with
a new story for these characters as well
as forging your own with new character
yes you know it's really exciting
because the first trilogy really
finished you know it finished with the
conclusion I mean all the emotions gone
all the locusts are gone so it was
really interesting to sit and think
about where do you take the story from
there a couple of things that we talked
about was where you could go with it and
knowing that you know now that microsoft
owns the IP and we know they're going to
be doing more of these and it's a it's
an IP we're going to invest in it gave
us a lot of leeway to be able to go in a
lot of different directions so we've
planned not just for this game but for
further down the road so we're really
able to do a lot more with the store
then we would have otherwise if you
don't know if you're going to be doing a
sequel later on so I must be exciting
it's reassuring it's exciting it's a
little bit scary because again these are
new characters right people love Marcus
and they love bear and they love Cole
and now we got to get him to love JD and
Kate and down and everybody else that we
introduced so that's challenging but
it's fun yeah how's the reception been
to the new characters so far really good
I mean and I expected people just to
love JD but through the playthroughs
we've shown in the demos we've done
today I've had people say I love del and
I love kayden and she's my favorite
character so that's really fun and and
to be able to create a diverse group of
characters is you know it's just great
for gaming and it's great for the
franchise and that's really what gears
has always been about it's always been a
really diverse interesting group of
players it was there any apprehension
about introducing you know especially a
girl into something which is very
traditionally male centric and really a
girl you said that not me no I mean
gears has always have really strong
female characters right there's been
Anya there's been Sophia Alex Bernie I
mean it's really not something new for
gears at all so we're really proud to
keep that tradition going and I think
what we're really excited about is is
this is as much Kate story as it is JD's
story and I think that's what's really
going to be fun for fans to discover as
they go through and play the game I mean
she's really a big part of this and I'm
now I know what's going to happen on a
super excited anticipating what the
reaction that we from all the fan base
but will spoil it for you can i'm not
going to spoil for anybody know there's
been too many spoilers for e3 already
i'm gonna keep this one to myself what
was it like putting it putting your own
stamp on Sarah because the planet is
completely different yeah it's tricky
right again you know you think about
what's going on with the planet after
all of the natural resources I mean
think about what would happen to earth
if suddenly all the gas was gone okay I
mean obviously we would be able to get
get home from e3 but beyond that I mean
there could have a lot of different
impacts and that's where we came up the
wind flares and stuff like that so the
you know the makeup of the world has
changed it's obviously reclaiming itself
from from 14 years of war and then the
25 years that are in between so it's
really it's a familiar environment but
it's also different and the way that you
learn about the outsiders and the way
that they live their lives as well as
the COG rebuilding all that plays a huge
part in the story what was it like
trying to build a story with all that
tension between these two factions and
then bringing it across the swarm these
new enemies that you guys created yeah
it's been great I mean you know the
original gears was a very distinct story
and they had the Strand and the
difference between the outsiders and the
stranded is the strategy were left by
the COG right they set off the light
mouse bombs and and they were just out
there which is why they're called the
stranded obviously Outsiders chose not
to be a part of the COG so when the
world started rebuilding after the war
you know most of the population was
wiped out and those that were left in
the COG had to rebuild so they became
very protective you know and it's oh we
don't want you to do these things we do
this everybody needs to be safely need
to rebuild population well it's just
like it is in our lives right we don't
want the government telling us what to
do all the time so there's certain
faction that wants to live outside that
and that's where the outsiders came from
so that tension between those two play a
big part in the story and I think that's
sort of the catalyst for what lights the
spark for further story let's talk a
little bit multiplayer rod announced at
the press conference horde three point
oh it's back what's different what can
you tell us I can tell you a little bit
about it it's going to be there going to
be some classes in it there's going to
be it is is built off the back of [ __ ]
two point oh so it's a bit odd that
people go well there's been five gears
of war but it's only [ __ ] to not every
gears had [ __ ] in it so for us we're
really excited about because it's a
familiar but different take on and we
think it really moves the ball down the
field a lot in terms of what the
experience is going to be in and again
like every part of gears there are
passionate campaign players there are
passionate competitive players but the
horde players I got to tell you emails
and
twix the Twitter messages I get is
always about hoard hoard horse so it was
super exciting to be able to tell fans
that's back and of course over the next
few months as we get closer to launch
will be able to start revealing a bit
more about what's going to happen
instead of horde I mean that literally
defined that type of gameplay when we
talk about swarms of enemies we call it
horde mode yeah I mean for Gears there's
really two things that I think define
gears and that's co-op play and horde
mode so we're really excited to have
both those in and have them be a
significant part of the experience is
co-op mode the best way to play the
single player I think so but that's
because I'm not a very good player
what's really interesting about that
though is that you've seen well if you
come by the booth you'll see the pouncer
for example in action that's one of the
characters that we created one of the
enemy classes that we created to be
specifically a co-op enemy so we built
some of the mechanics inside the game we
built some of the enemies inside of the
game to be co-op specific to really take
advantage of that so for us we always
say that that co-op isn't the icing it's
the cake so it's really a core to what
the experience is when we build
everything we think about coop first and
then we build out from there so if
you're playing in single-player you come
up against the bouncer are you really
going to struggle or is it kind of or is
it adapted a little bit if you play it's
adapted the AI understands the situation
that will help you out especially if you
get pounds because the pouncing is
interactive and you get stuck on the
ground in the different modes you can
get out of it when you get into hardcore
an insane yeah you get past you're not
getting out so so you guys a Ming for 30
FPS single player 60 FPS multiplayer is
correct what is 60 bring to the
multiplayer kiss well it brings a you
know it brings a fluidity that I think
is expected in competitive multiplayer
games and for us that's been great I
mean what we do again passionate fan
base we weren't so arrogant that we're
going to go off and do this without
consulting the fan base so what we've
done along the way is we've actually
brought in pro players multiple times to
give us feedback both on how it feels on
the new weapons on the new levels on the
new game modes we've we know we
announced things like escalation as a
new competitive eSports mode and the
feedback from the competitive players
and the professional players have been
really great they've helped really shape
the direction of where multiplayer is
going so speaking of eSports
professional players obviously microsoft
announced that the new arena for xbox
live is gears going to be taking part in
that yeah we'll take part of all the
obviously all the first party initiative
for us we're really excited about
anytime we can get the platform to take
something off our plate that's really
exciting and what platform does and it
means it's going to be something that's
going to be able to be used by everybody
which is which is even better right when
you have to roll your own solution it
tends to be specific to what your game
is so having platform really be
dedicated that and having Microsoft you
know take eSports seriously as you know
trying to make Xbox one the the premier
platform for eSports is really exciting
for us was it difficult to eSports
always in mind I know remember i
remember with gears remastered they had
you guys had like some kind of spectator
mode or some kind of definite esports
built-in initiatives for eSports base
yeah and it's funny because gear says it
was actually one of the original eSports
games and it just didn't really get the
support that it needed to grow at the
same rate as everything else so we sort
of looked that and again small but very
passionate fan base said please take
eSports seriously so again you know we
really spent a lot of time talking to
our fans and getting feedback from them
and and so you did see it in Ultimate
Edition where you have a spectator mode
we've got two now inside of sorry I call
it sparta which is the code name is
inside of gears for and that's really
going to be great for eSports because
you'll be able to set up cameras you'll
be able to switch a lot faster and one
of the things I think is they'll make
gears a really watchable East bored
event and when you think about sports to
me being a huge sports fan that ability
to be able to see the strategy and the
gameplay play out in front of you as
opposed to always just seeing it from
the from the character's perspective let
helps you understand more what the
strategy and the tactics that are taking
place over the course of the event is so
yeah we take that stuff really seriously
and will continue to iterate and improve
on that and release more features as we
go I hate to go off topic but I love it
when people mention the code names for
things yeah like sport is such a it's a
normal term I think for something like
this but where did you guys come up
without a name why sparta ah you know
it's it's just part of what microsoft is
about we use we use code names for
everything I mean you know what windows
95 was called Chicago every single
project that I worked on since the fact
it's very difficult to be an employee at
Microsoft be honest with you because
you'll be in a meeting and they'll
mention all these different code names
and if you're not in the know it's
really hard to understand what's going
on so it's just it's
you know as you saw this week leaks
happen and I think when you liek a code
name people don't really know what it
because it's not necessarily associated
with whatever the project is so for that
it's a way to keep it safe I think more
than anything so when you're moving
between demo stations do your handlers
have a code name for use like big bird
is on the move no no gir it would be
over if it was a so what was the thing
that you were most excited about showing
to funds and plays oh gosh that's hard
one there's so much more to show uh I
think every time I get a chance to show
something it's exciting because the team
works so hard on it and they put so much
love and effort into it and you know
they're really up in Vancouver working
hard on this evening well I'm down here
repping the repping the product for them
yesterday was great because it was the
first time to really get the fans got a
chance to see what the wind flares are
going to be like and all that dynamic
interaction in the world is all about we
showed that off earlier in some of the
private press stuff but it's the first
time the fans have seen it so you know
it's fun because that's one of the
things it's a little bit different about
the game that's maybe not traditionally
gear so getting the reaction and seeing
how fans are feeding back on that is
really fun and exciting so I mean you
mentioned we mentioned the fans a lot I
mean what what kind of feedback do you
get I mean is it like a bunch of tweets
is it detailed rundowns of things they'd
like to have you seen gears fan we are
the only fan base that I know of where
people get tattoos of the crimson omen
on them or Marcus or any of the other
iconography from from gears awards it's
phenomenal I mean we have they sent us
pictures of them using a Lancer to cut
their wedding cake I mean it's insane
these are the most passionate fans i've
ever seen and it's so exciting because
they are what's great about is there
they're so passionate about they want
you to make the game better and it's not
necessarily they want you to do their
ideas they just want you to be as
passionate about it as they are and
that's what's great about the coalition
as you have a group of people up there
that that feel the same way about it
take the responsibility of being the
stewards of Gears of War very very
seriously so all that comes into play
and for us we think that by having that
relationship with your fan base it winds
up giving you a much better product in
the end I actually have a battle toads
tattoo like I'm just really be going i
dunno i can't show it though cuz wait
what are you not safe for work oh my god
um so what I can't even do that right
now Chuck
thank you so much for joining us when
can fans get their hands on Gears of War
for well it ships on october 11 and if
you happen to go online at Gears of War
common by the ultimate edition you
actually get trans on at four days early
on October seventh you can have any more
pieces planned no more betas no no yes
all eat it all hang on I'm English sorry
I am English we're not logging baby I
understand so no from now on it's it's
spit and polish all the way the end so
it's heads down for the team up there
and we're looking forward to to all the
fans getting their hands on an
opportunity to play all aspects of the
game so awesome thank you so much for
joining us thanks for having me we'll be
back again tomorrow for day two of III
seriously you will not want to miss it
I've got the run sheet right here
honestly some of the games you got on
the stage tomorrow are incredible but in
the meantime head over gamespot com we
have written previews video previews
impressions of all the games here thank
you so much for watching we'll see you
tomorrow you're watching the game spot
stage brought to you by airheads